all right i don't usually do these
videos i don't know if this is a call
out video or what it is but it's about
carl benjamin you might know him as
sargon of akkad
and in my limited interactions with him
i've interviewed him once before we've
exchanged a few twitter messages
and he's he's left some comments on my
youtube channel uh he's been perfectly
nice to me and our our sort of
interaction started way back when this
gamergate thing was going on
and he uh had had sent a tweet
um
the the exact words escaped me now but
it was related to
video title choice on the david pakman
show youtube channel and allegations of
of click bait
in terms of title selection so i
interviewed him on the show about that
issue and we'll get to that in a second
long story short he was critical of
title selection and during the interview
i sort of explained to him the whole
point of titles is you know as long as
the title is accurate you want people to
watch
the video that's why you're doing it and
by the end of the interview he by and
large agreed with me and we'll get to
that video in a second but the reason
for this video is a bunch of people over
the last few days have been sending me
links to this video that he did called
the young turks are falling apart and
people saying david oh my god this guy
carl
they usually call him sargon but i know
him as carl
carl is just destroying the young turks
he's exposing that they fell apart in
2016. it's crazy what's going on over
there now that's interesting to me so i
my channel used to be part of the young
turks youtube channel at a certain point
a couple of years ago at this point
roughly uh i think it's been about 24
months a couple years
uh i separated from the young turks
because we were just growing our brand
independently completely friendly i see
a lot of the people from the young turks
once or twice a year at one conference
or another
um uh so i have no
reason to go out and try to either
confirm nor deny that the young turks
are quote falling apart but i thought
this sounds devastating it must be that
the young turks unbeknownst to me have
had some kind of major
financial crisis or that their their
subscribers or their views or something
has happened
i should check out the video
that carl did
to see what it's all about and i checked
it out and what i came away with was
that carl did by calling his video the
young turks are falling apart the exact
same thing that he came on my show to
criticize me for um a year and a half
ago or whenever it was so just to get us
into this let me first play for you
um
the conversation carl and i had
about this click bait issue and my
understanding from re-watching this is
he came in
very strongly criticizing uh and reading
off titles that i'd used and we sort of
ended with him kind of
seeming like he he had nothing else to
say about it and saying yeah what you're
saying is reasonable if the title
contains a reference to what's in the
video
um it makes sense that you would choose
a title that would make people want to
to watch your program so let's start
with that uh first and go from there
because i want to talk about in the time
we have left you you tweeted to me a
little while ago you'd be embarrassed to
be on my show because we have clickbaity
titles on youtube i wouldn't change that
i i didn't say that i would i said oh
you'd be embarrassed to be me right
no i didn't i said i would be
embarrassed to have a video with a title
uh the clickbaity title on my channel
because and let's be honest with
ourselves that was a pretty click-baity
title let's explore that though you know
i've had so many conversations with
people on and off air about this issue
of click bait for me the standard is
is the title accurate that's question
one right if the title is lying if the
title says something that is not
contained in the interview that's a
problem that's something i would want to
remedy right away but beyond that some
of the click bait kind of ad hominems
that have been used
seem sort of specious and capricious in
the sense that is the suggestion that we
use deliberately uninteresting titles
right i mean like doesn't everybody say
hey here's an interview where 10 things
were discussed shouldn't we pick the two
that might attract an audience or what's
the point of doing videos if the idea is
not to have people watch them i don't
get the criticism i mean let okay let me
um let me read out the title and i think
that um for people listening i think
they'll understand
my concern okay with this uh the title
was hashtag gamergate colon voxday it
says some races are smarter than others
and the gay is a birth defect right now
i mean just looking at that title
regardless of whether it's pertinent to
the video or not how are those subjects
pertinent to gamergate well the
gamergate interview that that interview
was tagged as gamergate because when we
said we're going to do a new round of
interviews around gamergate who should
we look at one of the the primary people
that was mentioned was was vox day and
his connection to gamergate was sort of
the catalyst for the interview but i
think that now there you may be
conflating two different things which is
whether you think that the interview is
related to gamergate and to whether the
title is quote clickbaity which is i'm
just having a really hard time
understanding
what the criticism is if clickbaity just
means it's meant to make people
interested and not deceptive isn't that
what everybody does i don't get it
i i think that um
that title is designed to put a specific
impression of vox day in people's minds
i mean i i personally had never heard of
vox day before your interview with him
so i i don't know anything about the man
i don't know what he does and i don't
really care to be honest okay um
but i mean
my my issue really is that it
it appears and i'm not saying that this
is what you were doing deliberately or
anything like that yeah to to someone
who hasn't watched the video and doesn't
know anything about gamergate it would
appear that you are trying to conflate
the issues that vox day was bringing up
which is uh some racist smart and others
and gaping birth defect with
gamergate itself because i mean yeah but
i don't know if that's fair because we
we tagged even our interviews with
anti-gamergaters we just tag it as this
is within gamergate we are not
necessarily linking any particular
statement to one side or the other you
know
well i i mean i i i can understand your
point of view there yeah i'm just saying
that what it looks like to people
outside of your position i think is that
and i'm not i'm not saying that's
necessarily fair either but that's i
think that's the impression a lot of
people got but so so as far as
clickbaity though do you think
what
how do how are we to define click bait
because again my my standard and it has
been since september 2nd of 2009 when we
started our youtube channel is
is the title reflective of what's in the
clip right that's priority number one i
can't say
uh vox day advocates killing babies if
that's not what he does in the video
that would be dishonest right so that's
kind of standard number one standard
number two is
is this a title that is going to attract
people or not we put a lot of time into
making these videos we want to have
titles that are going to attract people
people don't name movies or books or tv
shows in a way that says hey we spent a
ton of time on this let's come up with a
title that makes people not interested
so it just seems like a feeble criticism
um i think it's more the inflammatory
nature of what you've written there i
mean it does seem rather tabloid doesn't
it but if he did say those things right
he he he did say those things but
i guess the i i personally think the
onus if if this were me
the onus would be on me not to
write such a
blatantly inflammatory title and i don't
know how familiar you are with our
channel though because we've been for
years and years interviewing probably i
don't know 50 or 60 people who just say
very inflammatory things my feeling
would be if i deliberately keep the
inflammatory things out of the title i'm
actually kind of being deceptive right
if i put in something deliberately milk
toast in the title and ignore the fact
that the person said inflammatory things
what kind of uh what kind of a person am
i to to to to bury those things no
that's a fair argument you know
certainly uh
it's certainly not unreasonable okay i
mean i think that we would all be better
served going forward if we say
is the title accurate and if it is
then we can have a conversation about
what the goal is of of the title but if
the if the criticism is the title is
deliberately trying to make people watch
the video
welcome to media right i mean people
would not create media if the goal was
not to get others to watch i think you
would agree
well that's true that is true
okay so that's the conversation that we
had and when we had that conversation i
came away thinking uh yeah you know that
uh
that that that makes sense to me and it
seems like we have an understanding here
of uh sort of of of what's going on so
then again now we're gonna get into
carl's new video and this new video is
one where
he um
says in the title
the young turks are falling apart so
remember to remind you of what he said
you don't want inflammatory or tabloid
sounding titles and the onus is on him
as he said
not to write inflammatory titles so i'm
expecting based on what carl said on my
program when when everybody who's
emailing me says david you gotta check
out this video there must be something
here that makes the allegation that the
title makes the young turks are falling
apart
absolutely beyond question because
otherwise carl would be violating his
own principles of not having
inflammatory or tabloid-sounding titles
and that would be his onus so i'm not
going to play it's like a 20-something
minute
video
and you know you could check it out for
yourself uh uh it's it's um
you know
you may enjoy watching it you may not
you may watch it just to try to figure
out you know what is it that that is
being said but i will sort of just run
through
briefly the points that that carl makes
in the video
um and you tell me whether any of these
are evidence that the young turks are
falling apart the video starts with a
clip of jenk saying genkuger saying that
sarah palin
said the word people but it wasn't clear
if she said the word people so later
jenk apologized okay maybe it's a weak
beginning but that's not exactly
evidence of the young turks uh falling
apart
later he criticizes the young turks
because when during i don't remember if
it was the dnc or the rnc alex jones
jumped in to their set they cut away at
one point the young turks quote had to
cut away which means the young turks
chose to cut away again not exactly
falling apart
then
carl shows a clip of anna casparian
showing up and yelling in a way that
carl says isn't classy all right well
maybe his opinion is that what anna did
wasn't classy but again
it's not really the young turks falling
apart it's not a financial crisis it's
not a loss of audience it's not some
kind of technical issue that forced them
off the air or something like that
then the clip is played where jimmy dore
spits on alex jones yeah that's not
something i'd be doing i would not be
going around spitting on people um but
you know did it cause the young turks to
fall apart i think empirically the the
answer is no but i'm not gonna defend
spitting on anybody
um
then jenk misstated according to carl
the young turks channel being bigger
than alex jones channel in terms of
relative growth rates through november
something of 2016 you he puts the graph
up on the screen
all right i mean it's so i guess the
argument is at the alex jones channel
grew more than the young turks during
2016.
the young turks still had a good 2016 so
is that the young turks falling apart
i'm not really sure about that
then carl goes to a clip of the young
turks incorrectly assuming that donald
trump was not going to win the
presidential election
half or more of all media outlets said
donald trump was not going to win the
election yes they were wrong
most of them are still on the air most
of them are doing fine they haven't
fallen apart so i don't think you can
use that to say that the young turks are
falling apart
then carl goes to a clip of anna
casparian saying that she's better than
people who attack the powerless carl
disagrees with that and many people
might disagree hey no one's better than
anybody else no matter how deplorable
your political beliefs nobody can say
that you're better than somebody else
it's not the young turks falling apart
again it's carl doesn't agree with
anna's opinion and
that that is perfectly fine and
reasonable
um later anna says that she doesn't
respect women who voted for trump and
thinks they're dumb you may not agree
with that and it seems like carl doesn't
but to say that the young turks have
fallen apart as a result not really
borne out by the evidence
then there's this clip of a tyt fusion
joint thing at some college campus where
a kid gets up and asks anna about
uh sort of an implicit question about
the armenian genocide and the name of
the young turks etc
um and anna says she believes the
armenian genocide happened
and it was
entertaining and titillating in some
ways and it seemed like it was to carl
but again it's not it's not the young
turks falling apart and then lastly as
evidence of the young turks falling
apart or as presumed evidence i mean i
assume what's in the video is
supporting the title which is the young
turks are falling apart
carl accuses the young turks of
darkening a picture of sean king
to make his skin look darker
and he doesn't like that tyt has hired
sean king and that it's also not clear
whether sean king is black or not and
that apparently is part of the the case
that the young turks are falling apart
so
i i want to go back to carl's own
statements that he made now if the
explanation here is that i was so
overwhelmingly convincing in my
interview with carl
that he no longer cares about any of the
things he said during our interview okay
well that would be one explanation the
other explanation would be he's not
following his own guidelines which are
that it's his responsibility the onus is
on him not to write inflammatory
titles that are tabloid and of course
implicit in that is that the material in
the video doesn't reflect or defend or
support the title
there was nothing in the video that
supported the title which is the young
turks are falling apart it seems a
better title would be
carl
doesn't like some of the things the
young turks said during 2016
and maybe wishes they were falling apart
i don't know maybe that's a better title
as far as the data and again i don't
have any
interest
personally in defending or criticizing
the young turks they gained about a
million subscribers during 2016 which is
pretty good
uh and they had about a billion views on
their youtube channel during 2016 which
is pretty good
so basic question my basic question in
terms of click bait titles
does the title reflect what's in the
video
the answer here is clearly no